and what what
what hi guys welcome to Fred diary AKA
this week sat diary if you don't know
this is the video I make every week that
sort of rounds up my week and things
that I've done because
[Music]
we love living vicariously through
strangers that have the ability to edit
their life together to look way cooler
than it actually is watch this say no to
cigarettes say yes to Transitions this
is how my week
[Music]
started and then this happen hi guys
back in Los Angeles I haven't shot
anything of hardly just a riveting start
here and now it's already Wednesday so
I'm feeling really confident about my
content this week I am right now headed
I don't know if I'm allowed to talk
about this I'm assuming yes I'm headed
right now to shoot with Kingsley he has
a new show that he's working on and I
get to be a guest on it and I think it's
going to be really fun I love Kingsley
it's impossible to
not at least like feel kind of Sasser
when you're around him
no that sounds like a mom trying to
describe what it's like to be around
teenagers we're going to go shoot some
stuff with him now and then later today
um Goose comes to the new house to do
some training and I could be happier
okay I'm back from Kingsley shoot it was
really fun and guess what I could tell
you all about it because it already went
up online on Clever TV the link is down
below it was really fun and I'm sorry
that I didn't show you anything while I
was there classic vlogging what the [__]
are you doing I'm soor sorry I woke up
late today and I wanted to think of
something really fun but I didn't have
time I feel like you're just pulling
these ideas out of your ass you know you
have a nice ass it's great but you don't
have to pull [__] out of it all the time
I would just appreciate it if we could
play a game that has easy rules that
Grace can comprehend that she can do to
gets her ready for the show what what
what do you have something to say grace
I thought you laugh I can't the room's
really small and the door is locked and
I also have never been to this building
before now I'm home and I'm cleaning up
because goose and her trainer are coming
over to see the new house for the first
time and to do some training sessions in
here and I feel really anxious I feel
like feel like I need to impress her I
mean I feel like I've made some good
color choices here but she's color blind
so oh for all of you that don't know
goose is my dog um and there's her bed
waiting for her to come here before she
can officially like stay in this house
with me she has to come do some like
sessions where she gets acclimated to
the house and learns what behavior is
Toler able in this house and like
reprograms the way um she knows how to
do things because she is very aggressive
I'll try and film it no promises which
means I probably won't film
[Music]
it wish I could get in a time machine
and go back and relive this moment good
morning it is 8:30 a.m. on Thursday and
and I am headed to pick up mry heartt
and we are going to go record some voice
over for the hey USA full length
episodes that come out this month on uh
the scene.com I feel very reminiscent of
Camp Dakota days when I would pick up
mry on the way to uh to set we had
carpool together really early in the
morning but we're not doing it today
just to be like we're cute let's carpool
no her car is in the shop so um we're
doing it out of like practicality and
also friendship are you recording record
video we're here in our voiceover Booth
yeah look there's a whole team of
dudes and there's two Renegades right up
there hanging out are you ready for
this okay I don't have the
[Music]
licensing dare you but also this
prestigious thing
happened now we just all have gross
fingers
here you do it but I'll look like I'm
doing
it come on
you this is Monumental so now you start
it and then I stand up and you I show my
dick right before the time runs out [__]
got ground breaking good
morning I got some really great
purchases in the mail
oh dog on a plate
wearing really just stealing my look
hey cool
shirt I bought it guess where we're
going show them why did they
get I've made a choice I am dangerously
close to purpose of one of
these then the training session Goose
come on baby let's go inside yeah here
your dog door go ahead ready go here go
here you go good girl
[Music]
yeah
sleeping with my arm
just perfectly framing my face for
vlogging God what a disease so there you
go there was my week in an edit that
made it seem way cooler than it might
have been but you'll never know maybe I
kept all the really cool stuff off
camera no I didn't I don't
know
guys don't forget to pre-order my book
Grace's guide uh the art of pretending
to be a grown-up at Graces guidebook.com
I know I say it a lot but I just feel
like I should be consistent so here's
one more time don't forget to subscribe
if you like videos like this or if you
don't like videos like this why not
subscribe it's literally clicking a
button you probably just did that and
are doing it currently click one more
whoa congratulations